[Musique]
et bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de paca
peluche ne vous trompez côté bien sûr
votre attention mes chers auditeurs dans
55 minutes clôture de notre grand
concours de chant
j'y vais je suis sûrement la meilleure
annonce machata mien pardon pardon j'ai
une très belle voix bien placé nous
ferons tous très bien
nous allons répéter et nous irons en 30
ans ville devant le micro géo commence
[Musique]
rires moi
tél
m
[Musique]
les pas grave
l'autre
alors
[Musique]
oh
bah
[Musique]
-
bravo à mon tour maintenant
[Musique]
richaud
bien qu'il ait beaucoup plus
[Musique]
où
vos propos
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ce vacarme
nous répétons pour un concours de chant
vous avez de la chance que souhaite
bonne humeur de très bonne humeur
continuez continuez à moi moi attention
je commence
[Musique]
pas sûr
tu ne dis rien du tout ne cherchez pas
c'est gratuit
[Musique]
c'est très drôle très drôle je m'amuse
beaucoup aidé ces bonbons rien je vous
écoute avoue pas tacle ou alors des plus
rien ne t'a pas cela ferait avec turenne
papa tableaux ont porté plainte
c'est très dur dans l'hérault
je mets matin dans mes mains mais je
répète c'est l'autre avec un truc avec
les clés rien n'est tabou
l'a fait avec de rêve brad a clos on
peut recréer la tête inutiles écouter et
non mes chers jeunes vous allez entendre
le michael moore camp
le groupe je crie compte fait du bruit à
dole montrant on était plus content on
était moins bruyant ça a été que pour
mon temps on était tous
on était moins quand papa plus de
patache marque ça c'est trop fort
rien ne sert de bien chanter il faut
partir à point
et bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de pâte
à puce ne vous trompez pas notez bien
sur vos droits
attention ils ont à coeur
[Musique]